so for 300 years in this country there
was really no such thing as fair food
meaning that there was no way to
recognize from a consumers purchases
that workers were treated well in the
30s 40s and 50s a movement started in
California led eventually by Dolores
Huerta and Cesar Chavez that morphed
into the United Farm Workers Union and
people of a certain age my age and above
can remember not eating grapes or
lettuce in the 70s because of the
nationwide boycotts against produce that
wasn't picked fairly that wasn't picked
in those days by union members now
unions have been decimated all across
the countries in the 80s and 90s most of
the union protections that were won by
farmworkers were rolled back farmworkers
have two things against them number one
in many states most workers can't
unionize without the fear of losing
their job in Florida for example it's a
right-to-work state which means
euphemistically that if you decide to
unionize your employer can fire you just
for that California for example they
can't fire you because you're trying to
organize a union secondly according to
the National Labor Standards Act that
was set in 1938 by FDR that set the
minimum wage requirements for workers
all across the country farmworkers were
the exception farm workers and domestic
workers were predominantly African
American and in order for FDR to pass
that bill he needed the support of the
Southern Democrats who refused to let
their African Americans have the same
rights that workers all across the
nation were having so farm workers and
domestic workers were excluded from that
so fast forward to the present day and
age there are no unions farm workers
aren't really protected by national
labor laws they definitely aren't
entitled to overtime and what that means
is that for a consumer who's asking
themselves is my food fair the answer
99.9999
9% of the time is either no or there's
no way to tell my film food chains
focuses on one small group of workers
from Central Florida southern Florida
really called the coalition of Immokalee
Workers Immokalee is a Native American
word which means our home and it's a
little tiny labor camp in southern
Florida right next to Naples and I call
it a labor camp because it's got a
wintertime population of 40,000 people
when the harvest is in full swing but
there's no city council there's no mayor
there's no real infrastructure in that
city and it's only 15 miles away from
the richest ZIP code in America Naples
so Immokalee is a labor camp and in that
little labor camp some of the worst
atrocities in this country have happened
from modern-day slavery to sexual
harassment to really horrific horrific
crimes in the field but a little group
called the CI W the coalition of
Immokalee Workers created a program
called the Fair Food Program and that
Fair Food Program is really the only
program in the United States that
absolutely guarantees that workers in
the field earn more than sub poverty
level wages and are entitled to a
complete spectrum of Human Rights
guarantees they've gotten 12 major
retailers to sign on to that program and
what that means in simple terms is that
if you go to Walmart Whole Foods Trader
Joe's if you eat it almost any fast-food
restaurant in America except Wendy's in
the wintertime most likely your tomato
is from that program it's a fair food
tomato so if you want to eat fair you
can go to Whole Foods you can go to
Walmart surprisingly you can go to
Trader Joe's and buy there Florida
Tomatoes that's the only product in the
entire United States
that's absolutely guaranteed without a
doubt
to be fair labor
you